françois poulet mathis journaliste
spécialiste des institutions européennes
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors dites nous comment
expliquer cette surmortalité au royaume
uni on peut l'expliquer bien sûr sur le
retard à l'allumage pris par bruce
johnson au début de l'épidémie qui a
finalement nous pas pris tout de suite
les mesures qui ont été nécessaires pour
endiguer cette cette flambée de
l'épidémie
mais de manière générale l'angleterre
connaissent cette situation depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines et c'est
une situation bien sûr préoccupante
qu'il oblige finalement a changé assez
régulièrement ses réactions par rapport
aux réglementations vis-à-vis des
touristes par exemple qui doit venir ou
même des anglais qui doivent revenir
dans leur pays en particulier ceux qui
doivent revenir d'espagne
donc c'est une situation très instable
mais l'angleterre n'est pas la seule à
connaître cette situation puisque
d'autres pays qui se sentaient plus ou
moins à l'abri comme de certains pays du
nord comme la suède ont connaissent
aujourd'hui des flambée de l'épidémie et
puis d'autres pays encore
je pense notamment aux pays de l'est et
en particulier la roumanie et la
bulgarie qui connaissent des flambées
particulièrement inquiétant de
l'importance de la pandémie
bref tout ça pose un véritable problème
de lisibilité pour les gouvernements
comment essayer de bien contrôler une
situation qui elle est extrêmement
difficile à appréhender puisque le co
vide
et quand même une épidémie que nous on
connaît mal que l'on jerman et donc
c'est vraiment les deux grands problèmes
qu'il faudra gérer à la fois avoir une
visibilité pour que les mesures ne
paraissent pas être décidées en désordre
partout mais aussi faire en sorte
d'éviter à tout prix ce qui serait le
pire c'est-à-dire der confinement
généraux de toute la population de
chacun des pays
alors vous parlez de boris johnson le
premier ministre britannique qui a et
bien affirme qu'il a pris les bonnes
décisions au bon moment même s'il a eu
du mal à prendre au sérieux cette
pandémie qui a fait de nombreuses
victimes en italie et en france
notamment avant de s'installer au
royaume uni pourquoi il
ne sait pas tout de suite inquiété boris
johnson y croyait que quoi que le
royaume uni allait être immunisé je
crois je crois effectivement qu'il ne
croyait pas cette pandémie vous savez il
n'est pas le seul j'en connais un
responsable politique de haut niveau de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique qui
s'appelle donald trump qui a à peu près
eu les mêmes réactions de même que
jaillir ball sonara au brésil
c'était une réalité contre lesquels un
certain nombre de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement n'ont pas tout de suite
réagi d'où le fait que effectivement
dans ces pays là la pandémie a connu une
véritable explosion qui connaît un vrai
problème et donc ça c'est assez le grand
défi notamment pour l'europe aujourd'hui
46 mille personnes testées positives au
corona virus sont décédées au royaume
uni c'est le plus lourd bilan en europe
est ce qu'on peut parler de ratés dans
la gestion de la crise sanitaire
oui y'a raté visiblement de boris
johnson
il a essayé de se rattraper donc
puisqu'il a connu lui même les effets de
la maladie
li s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait
prendre ça au sérieux donc aujourd'hui
il essaie rattraper mais de manière
générale ce qui est intéressant c'est de
voir comment vont les jeunes cinq
considèrent aujourd'hui pour se
rattraper qu'une concertation plus forte
avec le reste de ses partenaires
européens
les partenaires enfin dans l'union à
peine 2 de laquelle il va il s'apprête à
sortir mais ils considèrent aujourd'hui
qu'une concertation entre les 27 pays
membres de l'orb et le royaume uni est
tout à fait nécessaire pour éviter cette
impression de désordre général on voit
cette impression de désordre notamment
par rapport aux autorisations ou non de
transfert de transit entre les
différents pays
les autorisation d'entrer sur les
territoires où les obligations de mise
en quarantaine ou en 14 n ou encore on
le voit sur le port obligatoire ou non
du masque en milieu confiné comme c'est
le cas par exemple dans les pays du nord
qui le considèrent que le port du masque
n'est pas obligatoire
bref toute cette impression de désordre
est quelque chose de très négatif
et donc il est nécessaire pour ça que
les 27 pays d'europe se concertera plus
ursula von der leyen la pression de la
commission européenne a constitué autour
d'elle un petit groupe dont le but c'est
tous les jours effectivement décidé
d'évaluer les situations pour informer
les défis différents pays membres de la
situation pour éviter cette impression
de désordre
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
françois poulet mathis je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes merci beaucoup